this is the last time Leah Croucher was
seen walking to work in February 2019
more than three and a half years later
her parents say their darkest fears have
come true after the missing person
inquiry became a murder investigation
and now another significant update we
have nominated a suspect in this case
his name is Neil Maxwell
however
Maxwell was found dead on the 20th of
April
2019 having taken his own life
Maxwell was a convicted sexual offender
in the six months before his death
police try to arrest him 18 times for an
alleged sexual assault he's now been
linked to the address in Milton Keynes
where police found human remains
alongside Leah's rucksack and personal
possessions it is unusual to name a
suspect
but we have also learned this week that
during the time when Leah went missing
and whilst the owner of the property was
not in the UK
Maxwell was the only person to have keys
to that property
this property is only around half a mile
away from where Leah Croucher was last
seen and during the police's
door-to-door inquiries they say they
visited it twice before leaving a
leaflet because no one had been
occupying it the only reason Maxwell had
access was because he'd been hired by
the homeowners to carry out some
maintenance work
as forensic examinations continue so
will the lines of inquiry into Maxwell
as police pieced together what exactly
happened to Leah to give her family
answers they've long been waiting for
Aisha zahid Sky News